I'm breakable the glass I love
unbreakable years ago thank you
and I was the only comic nerd and
explained to my friends like wow that's
awesome it's incredible so today if you
could yeah we shoot something
yeah unbreakable would you change
anything you know I thought about this
you know I certainly would would have
framed it differently in terms of
marketing I would have been open about
that it was a comic book movie and and
and use the idea which is somebody
tapped someone on the shoulder after
surviving an incredible wreck and
nothing's happening we said I think
you're a superhero as a movie itself I
don't know I you know I think about if I
could have framed it a little bit more
like every boy thinks their dad is
Superman but what if one kid was right
if I could frame just that statement
just this chiropractically adjusted just
5% I think maybe I would try to have
done something like that I specialize in
those individuals who believe they are
superheroes
[Music]
[Music]
so I'm Daniella by the way I was very
pleased to see 20 minutes of glass and
I'm really excited to see more so but
I'm excited you know I'm a woman and I'm
asking myself is there any female
superheroes only boys want to be
superheroes
you know that's a great question you
said your name was Anita banana Oh
Danielle I'm sorry I mean it's not
needed with somebody else
Danielle okay um that's a great question
definitely there are female superheroes
out there in the world I mean I would
consider Patricia part of the superhero
world for me she's part of the Horde and
the Horde is a group that is a super
year so you represent if there is M
night Shyamalan there might be an M
light Shambhala
what kind of movies does he do well I
think there's a little bit of that guy
in me as well you know I think I'm a
really dark movies but at the center is
you can sense there's a hopeful guy at
the center of it there that has a
positive outlook on the universe even
though I don't shy away from doing dark
things in my movies do you have a
kryptonite like Superman has kryptonite
at that point or David has water and do
you have the weak point these are great
questions man really good questions I
would say yeah you know it's winning and
it's everybody's kryptonite with
everybody every artists kryptonite is
when you stop concentrating on your art
when then the thing that you're trying
to say and you look up and you see what
the reaction is that's that's every
artists kryptonite that we should never
look up that's we should always
concentrate on the painting on the song
on the movie and learn how to do that
this is not a cartoon this is the real
world no way and yet some of us still
don't die with bullets some of us can
still bend steel I have been waiting
dupa stupid I mean I make the question
and you answer that looks so awesome and
you're such a great director right and I
was asking the is there any superhero or
super power which you think of stupid
stupid etc stupid
you mean in other movies yeah gosh no I
would never say anything bad or another
movie that's so nice
no I you know I even the smallest thing
can be powerful when I do think of ideas
when I even when I was thinking of other
other powers that that these guys could
have had or the other characters could
have the smallest little thing even any
instincts can be something great I have
like made up a game it's like paper thin
earth rock it's like unbreakable fifth
glass so if we could play it if I win I
could be in your next movie and if if
you weren't asked I write your script ok
it feels like you want in both ways is
that yes so can we play sure I'm
breakable unbreakable sitteth class
gotcha okay you mean split yeah I guess
that's split yes what did the thing
scissors no that's okay let's go okay
okay right okay ready
mm-hmm I'm breakable split glass look at
that you don't get to do either you
neither in the movie nor writing the
movie I think that's Facebook game I
hate
but I like left very much they thank you
what do we call you sir
first name mister last name
[Music]